hello everyone and welcome to the
battlefield one launched a live stream
brought to you by gamespot and a I'm
danmark to the rice of me is battlefield
expert westie now as you might have seen
on gamespot over the last four weeks
this man has been whipping for
battlefield novices comprised of some
taught YouTube and streamers into shape
ready for launch day he's try and make
them different squad training seems like
a distant memory it's been a while but
now i'm confident i think we learned a
lot and Westies teaching should stay
with us and get each the your planer I'm
actually feeling fairly confident
because like we're going up against the
public we've not we've not got Wesley
kind of shining waters at us but I think
we've got enough communication with the
team through pretty well Wesley so
knowledge ball him quite so much
information and we don't so much from
his tutorials that you know obviously it
seemed a bit different not having him I
think we all know the game I think we're
confident our roles mork and ready we'll
go to Rome rolls we know what to do
we've been till taught well I think
we've got a tactic sound I think we can
do a pretty good job son ok so these
four guys are already in actions let's
nail head over to some of the action
right now let us go for it let's check
out we've already got Brad they're
rolling along in a tank yet he's sitting
in the driver's seat here and it's one
of the it's the landship but he's gone
for the three seater version so he's
sort of riding it solo at the moment and
actually we should probably talk about
the map a little bit because as when we
played in the open beta which was all of
our training footage the guys only
played one map so this is going to be a
potentially brand new to them yeah it's
not forget I mean that this game has
been in early access but some of these
guys this may be the first time they've
been on it since the meeting he Brad
right here on the fire and his fire he's
the only one left alive at the moment so
the squad should really try and try it
on that on that flaming tank at the
moment he's not playing medic he's
playing cat and mouse with somebody
hiding behind this cover here and
because he's only got a machine gun he
can't blow the cover apartment shell so
yeah you can see him just hiding here oh
if general Brad seduce March straight
through there we go there we go now he's
getting a few hit miles don't he's quite
finished him off is he gonna go he's
gonna turn his tank see can't hasn't got
the angle are doing you should have just
oh he got straight through shouldn't he
yeah
I mean like this tank is going to
absolutely squash the enemy back in
flames I think he didn't get into a
narrow allium can I pop out pop out the
front he's pretty got enough time to
sort of repair that enjoying a little
bit all it took a hit there I'm just
going to flip over to spam fish because
he's now in a gunner I believe Browns
are now sharing a tank well this is
actually a good position here is there
on the D capture point which look at the
top the screen you can see there was an
enemy catchable I just saw the union
jack flag dropping right there
absolutely so now they're taking it back
for the German Empire and they are
losing a couple of their other flags but
I got mixed feelings about that but
sometimes just the presence of a tank
because you know that things absolutely
massive could be enough to scare enemy
infantry away potentially put them in
the path of some of your friendly
teammates who might be able to take him
down for you so he's doing a good job
here although he's taking some serious
damage from some of these other tanks
but it looks as if he's got it pointed
the right way I think spam fish is in
the tank with him using the cannon and I
think they just took down the enemy tank
that was a really good move there but
although they looks like they've taken a
fair amount of damage themselves right
now so here we go look to fend much
let's flick over to him and see how he's
getting are just so ready to the alley
and see the flaming tanks and there now
yeah be a hasty retreat as soon as he
saw that well you could see here he's
using the scout rifle to good effect he
did 97 damage it was really unlucky
finishing that guy off they're very
unfortunate there was those vital three
points so that cost him yeah def he's
back up though got Rocky's been
resurrected split back to him very
quickly get back up with it as a with
one of his teammates reviving email so
this is point F now they're trying to
contest yeah they are they're trying to
contest this point they're doing really
well they're about to neutralize it so
that will look good
in their favor we don't start earning
points though until it's actually their
flag so there could be a little bit of a
contest going on on the flag and
actually really neither team is really
gaining points and they're just getting
killed all the time so those sorts of
neutralizing each other yeah they are
exactly yes we're watching the the
training in the earthen beaters conquest
any doing work there with the rifle time
little bit alright that was fantastic
you switched over to the cable it's now
this is the Benny we know this is all
unlucky people to take out I can hear
him he shout and take out the track so
he's actually shooting at a part of the
tank could say he's actually leaving
yeah he's actually leading the spot he's
doing really really well you got the
present to the tank you had many they're
taking three players out with rifle
whole squad works the team there to take
that flag although they weren't all in
the tank together doing their little
different roles and we'll round the flag
or work in as a team and they managed to
take it what you had in the battlefield
in the open data is that you had this
almost continuous loop of players just
running around the map capping flag to
move on to the next one cap the flag but
what you've got here is now players a
sort of getting together and killing
each other now matters towards the score
so you could have a fight that's
completely separate from a capture point
maybe maybe a choke point maybe an
alleyway and that's going to massively
affect the score because of all the
death that's occurring at that point so
it could be that it ends up with
everyone just killing each other so
they've gained maybe 20 points and the
other team of game 24 so you're getting
closer and closer to the maximum point
bracket every single trying to kill
something they have lost that you
capture point as you can see here we're
on board with Brad he's moving back over
to you catch point lots of players on
the flag here lots of players on the
flag yet you've got mustard gas and gas
grenades going out as well this is the
mustard gas here I think actually I know
that's just the gas grenade which I see
anything we're all bored with Bradley's
doing some reviving as well this
fantastic he's just picked up spam fish
there here we go TV is on the rampage
right now who was on that he was prone
unfortunately got taken addresses who
flits over to him if we switch over to
benny here you can see he's doing a lot
of work here on the on the light tank he
switched to the assault class he was
playing scout but he's now with the
sport class he's with the 80 rocket gun
which can do a lot of damage to these
light tanks and I think the tank has
sort of retreated round the back of the
objective here yet throwing some light
grenades trying to make sure speculative
late Oh buddy second-guessed him yet our
players are actually two of our players
the top of the scoreboard this is what
we like to see Joe we've got two little
groups here we've got spam fish and Brad
who are near the top of the leaderboard
and we've got Benny and camera a little
bit further down but they cannot shop in
a change in class i forgot to say I was
not expecting those guys to be the ones
who are sort of no I I hiring about for
the squad or I'll degree with you now
they're holding this is always doing
well just this is back at F again this
has been the most hotly congested point
of the game i'd say the enemy team this
is their flag it's the first one they're
going to want to take back so I've got
Brad some picking up some kills on the
top left side all viable bring this down
to the final five points now I think at
this point there is a British e that is
it that would be done that was a really
really good round the score an
incredible result coming out of that you
must be proud of the boys yeah I am
actually you know I'm its kind of
submitted my impressions though because
as we were just saying at the end of the
round there didn't quite expect Brad and
spam to be at the top when they're the
one who's supposed to be supporting the
others but actually they got in their
own tank and they went job we're just
gonna go for it it was saw the inverse
of what we were seeing drink yes exactly
but you know what that that's something
on that map it's close quarters infantry
it's an urban style there's not much
space to move for infantry then put a
tank in the middle of that the enemy
infantry are just going to run out front
of it you've got machine gun right when
I take you down cannon on the side
you're gone all the covers gone as well
the enemy team did really stand a chance
so obviously they're a great squad there
for for for as far as i know in
signatories that's a hundred percent
record we are happy and you've got some
glimpses of the excellent campaign as
well do not forget the battlefield one
easy out right now thank you so much for
sticking with us with this wesley thank
you so much for your insight accusing me
here thank you so much to our squad well
until i yes well done squad for their
sterling effort and thanks to you for
watching that's all from us let's play
the excellent battlefield want launch
trailer one last time see you later see
ya PEGI 18
get the new xbox one s